it's a great feeling I was like so happy
people don't understand it took so much
work so much work I've been working
since I was a baby and to do this it's a
great happy coach kept trying to get me
to come to Rogers good if I wouldn't
want the winter hat winter Roger I want
to be where I am today
deficit that's him Toledo's he'll always
be in my heart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in fact this would like everybody get
this this man is a legend I don't put
him in the books I would be upset let's
hear the opening comments from the
legend they're all they gave a little
bit of questions I'm just I'm just proud
program and also I just want to say the
support from Toledo was hubris today we
came out strong and we bringing it back
home and come back to back it's a it's
amazing finish that's mr. Madison
feeling because it was a lot of work to
train these young ladies are just
dedicated to the game and they won our
class